sort of started thinking about market
design you know 25 or 30 years ago I
started really trying to understand not
just how the rules of the pricing rules
and the auction rules sort of affect
behavior in the auction itself but how
those spillover into the market
structure and the the broader incentives
of market participants and so you know a
long time ago I said she started working
on timber auctions when I was an
undergraduate at Duke in 1988 and
they're already you could see in a lot
of the descriptive analyses of the
timber industry how important market
design was for affecting who
participated and so just as an example
they were looking at the difference
between first price and open ascending
auctions and it turned out that this
affected behavior and the auctions but
not according to just the static theory
it affected the incentives to collude
and it also affected the entry of small
bidders and so I worked on a number of
papers that showed how how that played
out and models that were basically
theoretical models that were then you
estimated using structural estimation so
data calibrating those theoretical
models to look at the impact on welfare
when I went to work on online markets
you know a couple decades after that one
of the first things I noticed when I
worked on search advertising markets was
again that the it was it was easy for
people to think about things like you
know first price and second price
auctions in online advertising but again
the really important things for the
performance of these markets was who
participated and and how they behaved
and so the the rules and changes in the
rules would have short-term effects that
looked really different from the
long-term effects and sometimes you for
example you might introduce a feature
that would be that looked beneficial in
the short run but if it was used
differentially by large sophisticated
advertisers it might make smaller
advertise
less profitable and then most likely to
participate in the marketplace so you
know and then we fast-forward from you
know these simple kinds of auctions to
through you know online advertising and
now the the really exciting new
applications are all in this sort of
service economy gig economy and we've
now are seeing questions about whether
enabling you know small suppliers or
sort of independent service providers
who are basically like operating very
small businesses whether these new
marketplaces allow them to enter which
is presumably can be really good for
welfare in those markets but also we
have concerns that allowing all these
small service providers to enter can
hurt quality and I'm you know Kiara has
been working on this from other from the
perspective of Licensing but broadly you
know we if we want to get the benefits
out of this sort of new flexible economy
we're going to need to deal with with
incentives for quality and in managing
these marketplaces and I work with a lot
of of different large platforms and
practice one of the most important
things you do as a marketplace designer
in the service economy is actually try
to incentivize people to do what you
want them to do so what is it that you
want them to do you know in in say
Airbnb or verbo or Rover these are
different platforms that I work on you
need people to keep their calendar
up-to-date to respond to their emails to
provide accurate product descriptions to
go the extra mile to make the customer
happy
and so actually rather than if you if
you go in and see like what are the
problems people are working on trying to
extract a little bit more of the
transaction by changing the prices is
not what people are mostly worried about
that's not the biggest problem
that's kind of the zero some part of the
problem but it's it's not as interesting
what's actually the the the focus of
most of the investment and research and
an innovation is about trying to say use
rankings to induce people to provide
better quality and to behave in better
ways in the platform so that's like the
central problem faced by all these
people and that again relates back in
the online advertising it was just about
the engagement of the advertisers
getting advertisers to write good ad
copy to run experiments to better target
their ads to the right users getting
that engagement was part of the quality
for the user so this is a theme across
all of these different things so I've
been doing empirical work to try to
understand some of these things and I've
been studying that in news as well as in
ride-sharing and I'm mostly going to
talk about ride-sharing today and I'm
going to show evidence and ride-sharing
that these marketplaces and the
different institutions they bring in
actually are good for quality where in
news they actually are generally going
to be bad for quality and there's good
economic reasons why it's different in
the different circumstances and as we
start to get more nuanced understanding
of the different economics we can avoid
kind of painting these things with a big
broad brush and instead really focus in
on which categories we should be
concerned about quality and which we
should I mean the empirical papers its
quantitative so I generally you know a
key well that you know starting to zoom
in on ride-sharing a key welfare benefit
of the gig economy is flexibility and so
a bunch of researchers have done
empirical papers on uber and provide use
revealed preference information and
structural estimation to show that the
drivers really value their flexibility
and they the way they figured this out
is by looking at how drivers respond to
variations in per hour pricing things
like surge pricing so they provide
evidence that basically for at least for
the lot of the marginal drivers that
they are very they really value the
flexibility to achieve and that makes
sense and that's really a theme of the
gig economy we have underutilized
resources I have two hours between
classes I'm a mom and I've got to drop
my kids off at school and pick up at
school there's a zillion holidays
you know there's kids get sick but I can
come in and provide labor at a time
that's convenient for me and so that's a
big benefit but if we if we have a lot
of ex-ante screening licensing
requirements and so on we're not going
to be able to get that benefit from the
it from the gig economy
I should by the way I should just
highlight that I do understand that
overall you know life has gotten worse
for certain types of drivers that used
to live in a different world and their
wages have gone down so I'm not
unsympathetic to that but I'm taking is
given that we've moved to a new world
and then I'm within that new world the
benefits side has to do with flexibility
the benefits for the world so
marketplaces are basically replacing ex
ante screening and training with ex post
monitoring feedback nudges and ratings
so there's this whole suite of tools
that they have to try to get people to
do higher-quality and if I just think
about the case of
ride-sharing you can imagine two
different theories one theory is that
there's drivers have different abilities
and so screening is going to basically
keep out the low ability people allow in
the high ability people and keep us all
safe the second theory is that like
pretty much anybody can drive but
there's a lot of incentives here and you
know if you have no incentive to provide
high quality then you'll you know jerk
around and swerve in and out of traffic
and slam on the brakes and if you do
have an incentive you'll provide a
better quality service and so of course
it's an empirical question which one is
which and that's what I'm gonna try to
measure now if you and there's a bunch
of differences between say taxis and
ubers generally marketplaces do more
than just you know evaluate your direct
performance there's also a psychological
difference so and actually the
platform's do a lot to promote that in
fact that's one way they can induce good
behavior on both sides so the uber
driver like talks to you and you have a
more inner there's the expectation of
more interaction where the taxi lives
this barrier and there's just this idea
that you know you're separated and when
you do an Airbnb or verbo the lot of the
high quality sellers will actually try
to establish a personal interaction with
you and there's a
reason they do that because there's also
moral hazard on the rider side of the
market or them or the renter side of the
market people trash people's houses and
you know I have also worked with Turo
which says car sharing people trash
people's cars and so if you remind the
consumer that actually there's a human
being on the other side of that
interaction they behave better too so
I'm not gonna study that part today I
think that would actually be really
interesting for future research but
these are I just want to highlight that
there's actually a whole bunch of
different tools at the disposal of these
marketplaces to solve these moral hazard
problems so what I'm gonna try to do
here is study this empirically with uber
X and taxis and I got this idea a few
years ago when I learned about the
amazing telemetry that can come out of
your mobile phone so I learned that and
I learned this actually from some
startups they're startups out there that
basically take the telemetry from the
phone and then provide as a service to
fleets a scoring of safety and when I
saw how how incredibly accurate and and
informative that was I immediately
realized that this was going to be a
very powerful technology for a whole
bunch of purposes and so if you want to
think about comparing quality it's
actually pretty hard to compare the
quality of you know a hotel and a verbo
or an Airbnb it's hard to compare the
quality of a rental car to a Turo
because there's a lot of differences in
those products but in the case of
transportation it's much more clear
you're trying to get from point A to
point B you basically need the same
service and I connect through telemetry
I can actually measure the quality of
that service and an apples to apples way
that's that's not really feasible in a
lot of other market places so I
approached Eber and said hey can I
actually use your data to do the study
because I think it's I think you're
actually going to see differences
between the ubers and taxis anybody my
age who's ridden in taxis doesn't have a
lot of doubt about which one is
providing me a better service so I had a
strong hypothesis about how this was
going to turn out but I thought it would
be really interesting to actually
quantify that so uber is is going to be
okay it's gonna be providing a service
that's different
bunch of ways now there's a bunch of
scum when people say safety and uber the
first thing they think about is safety
from driver climb now in the u.s.
despite headlines this is really a minor
issue it's a minor issue for taxis in
ubers both but you know in developing
countries actually everybody pretty much
understands that the Ebers are actually
a lot safer because often the taxis are
in cahoots with the local police and
people the the taxis are often kind of
part of you know some sort of organized
crime where they kind of hold you up and
extort from you and then they don't get
prosecuted so the the monitoring of and
knowing who was your driver and the fact
that they actually aren't part of this
old cooperative can be more safe but
we're also not gonna talk about that in
this paper yeah Nicole yeah being I sure
so we're not measuring that here yeah so
I don't know about the the US I think
that the anecdotal evidence from other
countries where the whole problem is
larger is that the Ebers and taxis are
again generally better and I think
that's just from a theoretical
perspective that's really clear just the
accountability is very different in some
sense if you wanted to be a criminal on
uber or lyft you basically are going to
be a criminal once if you're gonna be a
criminal on a taxi you know you can
potentially sustain that for quite a
while and so but I'm not going to try to
measure that and so another so what I'm
gonna measure is driver safety which you
could imagine calibrating in terms of
probability of accidents I actually did
not have data on accidents so I'm not
going to do that but actually even just
looking at probability of accidents is
not going to exactly capture what
consumers want because consumers like if
you didn't want to get an accident you
wouldn't ever get in your car and
probably some of you have had the
experience of telling your driver that
you're late for a plane so there people
have preferences about speed and you
don't actually want people to drive at
the safety optimal speed you actually
might have preferences about what about
getting people to drive faster so we're
gonna really focus on responsiveness
customer preferences in this paper but
we're also going to be able to say
something about safety just from what's
known from other sources what we're
gonna do is we're gonna look at the
region of Chicago this is the region
we're analyzing and the reason we picked
Chicago is because in Chicago the uber
app is used to dispatch taxis so we're
going to get identity limit RIBA tween
the uber X's and the taxis and that will
allow us to compare sort of apples to
apples now just to get started let's
talk about what's the difference between
the taxis in the uber is they do have
different financial incentives so they
have a somewhat higher base fare but the
charges per minute and per mile are
roughly two times higher for taxis and
ubers so at least the the relative
considerations are similar for the two
within uber X there are quality
incentives and nudges so in inside ubirr
X you get a rating which is the average
of your last 500 rides and you also see
the most recent rating there are a state
rating face incentives which I'll show
you in a minute
and there are also safety monitoring
Xand warnings and we're gonna study the
rollout of those in an experiment as
well so generally low ratings and
complaints are relatively uncommon but
actually poor driving and slow driving
are among the more common complaints and
I wanted to highlight the slow driving
because actually the speed is the
hardest thing to get out empirically
here because people's preferences are
non-monotonic
and so we in certain cases I'm going to
break out results by things that
includes B than and don't include speed
because our speed results are gonna be
well though we use machine learning to
fit the functional form blah blah blah
because of the non monotonicity z' the
the functional form matters for speed
and so you can think of our results as
possibly being less robust to speak so
when we look at the ratings in this
marketplace like many marketplaces
basically like everybody gets a 5 and
that's a problem for trying to use
ratings to help improve quality because
they're just the rating itself is not
that informative on a particular ride
you're not getting much information out
of it and of course rides are also not
always rated and
the propensity to rate is not random so
the using the rating itself as an
outcome to measure quality while in
somewhat informative or informative on
average is not going to be informative
at a very micro level and this is a
problem actually we had in in
experimentation in the search engine as
well you had things like conversion rate
or you know conversions from an ad so
just a consumer click on an ad go to
your website and buy something those
conversion rates are very very low and
then not all advertisers shared
conversion information so if you wanted
to see whether something you did
improved quality of ads and conversion
rates
actually you could look at it on average
if you had a large you know
multi-million user experiment but if you
tried to cut it down into this vertical
or this type of query you would very
quickly lose statistical power and be
unable to to see any statistically
significant results so the rate and this
this scenario is actually really quite
common across marketplaces where there's
some kind of measure that you've quality
you'd like to have but it's sparse and
has other problems in terms of being
operationalize above for evaluating yes
so actually in the time we're looking at
we didn't have the tips who are new so
we don't have tips data in here but come
you could come back and look at tips as
well and that that might be you know a
better follow on paper I should say
we've been working on this paper for a
little while and we've just gotten it
released because there's a lot of new
data in here so it was actually quite a
bit of effort to get all of this
analysis sort of through through all
layers of approval okay so the so when
we look at the incentive systems so when
you go below a 4.6 you get a warning
below 4.5 you get another warning and
you become temporary deactivated at 4.4
then you can go to a quality improvement
course and then you would be if you
don't maintain above there you'll get
permanently deactivated but again you
need to they look at 25 trips since
react
so even though you bird rivers are kind
of talk about being afraid of getting
kicked off it's actually really hard to
get kicked off of uber and they get a
lot of chances and warnings before that
would happen and so just to see how many
people are in these buckets in the data
set we're looking at we actually see a
very small percentage of drivers being
in the range where where these things
are going to be operational so from an
incentive perspective although as an
economist it might be nice to say oh
well you know this is a market where
incentives like rating based incentives
have fixed quality problems I think it's
very hard just from even a
back-of-the-envelope before you start
the analysis to come to that conclusion
because it's so hard to get kicked off
and so we're good we're gonna see is
that the the the differences will be too
large to be explained by that yeah these
are these are the thresholds that were
in operation in Chicago at the time as
as you well know in these tech firms
things change all the time so actually I
don't know what they currently are today
ya know so that is a difference between
taxis and ubers that they get they have
this incentive system but they I would
argue that it's only a small percentage
or really feeling that incentive at a
moment in time yeah Andre is very
responsive to ratings uber I seems less
if you have some metric for like
4.6 rating as a driver we might more
likely to be canceled on like what's
that development I do not know how how
those ratings affect rider response but
my intuition is that also it hasn't
really been it's not really exposed to
the to the right that riders because
they're gentlemen just taking what's
being assigned now very recently there
have been new introductions like now I'm
a diamond uber remember and so I'm
supposedly getting better drivers and so
presumably that's also providing an
incentive for the for the drivers
exactly so in principle there are other
incentives operating here but I would
argue that they're not they're not huge
they they wouldn't be responsible for
all aspects of behavior yeah but just
these numbers don't necessarily support
a future it could be detectives are
working yeah exactly so at a moment in
time for a particular ride most drivers
are not worried about these incentives
but it's certainly keeping them from
behaving badly all the time
exactly that's it to try to do the back
of the envelope we looked at how many
how many drivers would be at risk of
getting of passing different thresholds
a four point six threshold of four point
five threshold and a four point four
threshold if the next end trips received
a three star rating we saw it's pretty
hard to get a three star rating and so
we just say okay if if how many drivers
would it be that if they got twenty
three star ratings in a row would be at
risk of passing the four point four
threshold and it's still well below 5%
but if I looked at how many drivers
would get their first warning after
getting twenty three stars in a row you
know now it's getting closer to fifteen
percent so it's it's it's presumably
they're in their minds but it's not it's
not an immediate threat to get kicked
off so it's if these these are operating
through through other channels it could
also be and we're going to show some
evidence that supports this can also be
is partly psychological just that people
like uber has said four point six is bad
I don't want to be near four point six
but
cuz I don't want to be bad but not
because I think I'm gonna get kicked off
if I get 24.6 okay so then we do a
little bit of descriptive analysis so
here are some of the telemetry metrics
we look at being mounted being handling
the phone hard brakes hard accelerations
and then we have some speed metrics so
the speed is actually a very
multi-dimensional so every block you go
through the trip is rated in its speed
as a percentile of other trips through
that same physical block at that same
time so if you if you go from you know
here to the airport if you go through
you know 150 blocks each of those 150
blocks gets a percentile so we had to
try to figure out how to use that very
high dimensional data and so one of the
things we looked at was the the kind of
percentiles of the percentiles like
below the 10th percentile of your
percentiles and the say the the 90th
percentile of your percentiles or the
20th percentile of your percentiles of
the 80th percentile of your percentile
so it's basically saying like in your
ride is there parts of your ride that
are much lower than average in other
parts of your ride that are much faster
than than average and so just as
descriptive statistics we'd try to
decompose each of those metrics into
rider effects trip characteristics and
the residual just to see sort of what's
explaining them one thing again with
speed point out that the trip
characteristics explain a relatively
high share of the variation for speed
while it's it's less for the other types
of metrics that's another reason we
break out speed because speed depends a
lot on exactly the trip that you're
doing and we're gonna try to compare
different trips that are they're not the
same trip and so we also might be more
sensitive to mistakes or specifications
we do in comparing trip to trip for
speed because it's so important the trip
is so important we also see when you
actually look at the rating itself the
rider explains a huge part of the
variation in ratings which is another
reason that rate a rating a specific
rating on a specific trip doesn't
that much about the driver instead tells
you about the rider so at least if
you're gonna use ratings to actually you
know it give incentives to drivers maybe
you should be taking out the right or
effect first because it's so big and
that would give you a better thing and
so generally one of the kind of
operational things that I feel like
comes out of our analysis is that in
general these platforms should move away
from the the star ratings themselves and
be sure constructing their own metrics
that help them help them do a better job
monitoring and actually when I give this
paper from a to AI conferences I
actually talk about how exciting this
whole technology is from the perspective
of worker safety across the economy
because once you realize that you can
you can look at workers whether it's
cameras on an assembly line cameras on
customer service people emails with
customer service people and you can
label it as good or bad then you can use
machine learning to come up with a score
for every customer interaction or every
worker action and actually use that to
try to improve safety and quality across
the economy and I'm actually once you
once I wrote this paper I was like oh
yeah that's gonna happen and it turns
out yes it is happening in fact and it's
gonna accelerate over the next couple of
years
um so then what we do is we but the
safety metrics of course have unclear
interpretations complex interaction
effects as well as non monotonicity so
what we do is we build a model that
predicts ratings as a function of safety
metrics and we also include fixed
effects for the trip for example and we
so what we're trying to look at as well
as for the driver and what we're doing
is basically trying to say what is if
the metrics improved how much would that
improve ratings and so we want to think
about you know being able to compare
across trips that if this was holding
everything else fixed if the telemetry
was higher in this metric the customer
likes it more so we tried a bunch of
different functional forums we ended up
with because there's a fair bit of
smoothness like things are either
monotone or parabolic we found that hola
so with polynomials did the best in
terms of fitting the data these are some
subjects and pictures of the the
predictive model showing that there's
interaction effects and
monotonicity x' i don't have time to go
into that now it was my here um okay so
thanks so when we we're gonna this this
these indices actually there's a whole
statistical theory about it it's
actually something I've been working on
with Rush Teddy heat a women's and and
some cang where we are trying to
actually develop a good theory of
creating these indices and part of the
reason we wrote the paper Raj Chetty
needs to do it for his papers about
school performance I needed to do it in
search engines in fact I introduced a
bunch of these kinds of metrics when I
worked on the search engine and and now
it was coming up again in the in this
ever paper and basically what we're
trying to do is create use intermediate
variables that are either better
available because they're faster or less
missing than the final outcome you care
about so if you care about people's
final income after 20 years test scores
might be a prediction of that but we're
not going to wait 20 years to see if
class size improved student performance
so we have to use intermediate metrics
the conversion example was the one I
worked on in in advertising and here
there's another example where again
there's problems with the ratings
directly but we have all of these
telemetry which basically gives us much
more fine tune very and much more
variation from trip to trip than the
rating itself so it turns out that
there's two setups where this can be
useful one is that you see the
surrogates but you only see the final
outcome in say part of your data and
that when we compare over to taxis
that's one way to think about it in the
taxis there are ratings but basically
nobody really uses the ratings and the
ratings don't mean the same thing for
the taxis so basically it's as if we see
the ratings for the uber drivers but we
don't see them reliably for the taxis so
we're gonna build the model mapping the
surrogates the telemetry to the ratings
in the uber data and then but then we
see the same telemetry the same
surrogates in both the taxis in the
Ebers and so we create a score that can
be compared apples apples
the second thing we have is in when we
analyze an experiment that I'll show you
we actually do see the circuits and the
ratings in this experiment because the
experiment was just done on uber drivers
but it turns out there's still a
statistical efficiency gained from using
the intermediate metrics and the reason
for that is that if under the assumption
that all of the impact of of the
experiment is captured by the surrogates
and that the treatment doesn't direct
doesn't change the relationship between
the telemetry and the ratings then
pooling the data across treatment and
control to estimate the relationship
between the surrogates and the final
outcome gives us a more efficient
estimate of the final outcome
relationship and that increases power
and again this is something that we saw
in practice when I did this in the
search engine so in our in our paper we
developed that theory so that's going to
justify what we do and so basically here
we can have some covariance X this is
like trip characteristics s the
surrogates are the telemetry and we're
gonna have some kind of treatment that
effects the surrogates and what we're
gonna we're really only going to be
interested in the these treatments like
uber X versus taxi or an experiment
we're only interested in their the
effects that go through the telemetry so
the subject of the paper is the quality
of the ride is measured by telemetry but
rescaled as an index of customer
satisfaction so let me keep going here
so here now I have these scores and I'm
gonna have a full score that includes
all the telemetry a speed score that
just looks at the speed metrics and then
a score without speed that throws away
the speed metrics for the reasons I
talked about before we use three
different estimators to compare uber X
versus taxis the the first is a matching
estimator and it turns out it just
doesn't matter which one we use the
first but the matching estimator is
easiest to interpret so we can think
somebody's standing on the corner and
they're either gonna call an uber X or
an uber taxi and I want to understand
how much safer is their ride gonna be if
they call an uber X so to do that we
take the starting point the ending point
and the our block of the week and
forever
uber taxi ride we find the closest uberx
ride and then we throw them away if we
don't have a good match and so that's
what we're left with and here we
basically have about 80,000 uberx
I mean you burped AXI trips that can be
matched with uber X now we have many
more River X trips so we have millions
but in fact the estimates are going to
be similar when we use say fixed effects
for the for the trip partly because
essentially for the for the trip the
fixed effects are so small that in the
in the cells that don't have both an
uber X and an uber taxi ride those are
basically just discarded so it gets back
to basically the same thing whether we
do the fixed effects of the magic okay
and so basically what we find is that
the uber X's are substantially better
according to all of these scores than
the uber taxis and partly because we
have we have a lot of data that we get
precise estimates and the metrics are
scaled in terms of scar rating star
ratings and the the standard deviations
are about 0.02
then we go to look at heterogeneity so
we looked at a couple of different types
of rides off-peak rides morning rush and
an afternoon rush and we we find some
differences that the the gaps between
the uber and the taxi or actually say
smaller in the morning rush hour and
that might be when the people are trying
to get to work and they're asking their
uber drivers to hurry in which case that
ubers the the taxis kind of race around
all the times want me to think about it
the uber drivers can be relaxed but if
you ask them to speed up and to kind of
provide a more aggressive ride to get
you to work on time or to get to the
airport or things like that then they
will close the gap and drive in a more
aggressive way um then we try to
understand just try to unpack a little
bit of why this is going on so we look
at the driver responsiveness to their
last rating now in general there's going
to be lots of things that induce serial
correlation among the ratings and
so we do is we use an instrumental
variables approach where we instrument
for the last rating a driver got with
the ratings that other drivers got in
that same hour of the year so right now
this particular hour of the year it's
raining and everybody's dinging there
uber drivers then you know this
particular uber driver is more likely to
have gotten a bad rating and so that's
the that's the natural experiment we're
saying if you were driving in an hour
where everybody was getting bad readings
how do you change your driving behavior
in the next ride and so what we find is
that the if your last rating was bad
your next rating is good is good and so
the drivers sort of turned things around
like that seeing that oh my gosh I just
got a bad ride they kind of jump right
back into gear and they try to do things
that will make the next driver the next
rider happy whether it's offering them
gum giving them a power cord whatever it
is yes exactly they see two things that
last 500 and the last one so they would
see that now when we go to the to the
safety though we basically get pretty
precisely estimated zeros so they're not
so and I think this is probably accurate
actually the drivers are perceiving that
the best way to get their ratings up in
the next ride is to you know tell them
please give me a five give them gum
smile be nice but actually driving a
little bit more safely is probably not
going to have a huge impact on your star
rating and so they're not really
adjusting in that way so that they may
overall understand that the driving well
helps them get good ratings but it's not
the it's not the most actionable way to
kind of get a quick fix back to your
rating and I think this sort of also
just suggests that there's a little bit
of behavioral thing here that they may
just be forgetting to smile and be nice
and so just getting reminded is kind of
getting them to kick in there their
behavior okay so we then we look more at
this warning thing so we look at the
whole warning system this is a little
bit less well identified but we look at
how do people respond
when they get a warning but also how do
they respond when the warnings get
removed so if they bring their rating
back up they get another message that
says hey your warning has expired you're
back in good graces and so it turns out
that whether they're getting a warning
that says you're doing badly or they're
getting a message that says that their
warning is expired in both cases they
improve their behavior which is again
sort of consistent with more of a
behavioural assumption of being reminded
to do a good job rather than a pure
incentive yeah exactly
so that suggests that they should be
doing more kind of coaching and I think
this is actually from an AI perspective
actually this is really the promise of
this technology is that if you can
actually just get people to do a good
job of course at some point people stop
paying attention but if you manage the
behavioral of approach with people
that's a very cheap way and it can
actually make everybody feel better as
well well right now if you give a rating
you might feel really guilty giving a
three star rating so the consumer
doesn't like giving the ratings it's
very noisy for the drivers so the rating
itself this sort of may not be the best
way to tell people but if you instead
just tell them here's a way to improve
that might be more powerful and that
basically leads us into the expiry and
experiment so we we analyze an
experiment to provide safety information
to drivers and basically the way this
was implemented it was a tab in the
driver app that showed various safety
metrics the drivers then there were nuts
to get them to look at the tab but the
safety information was not explicitly
used in the incentive so in particular
when they would see this they would see
learn about your driving this is
automatically generated and it's just
for you so it's not going to be shown to
anybody else that's just basically
saying this just for you messaging is
that it doesn't affect your account
status in any way okay
so then this is what the information
would look like it can sorry it's a
little blurry here but you can see that
these drivers were getting these this
driver here was getting orange
exclamation marks which means their
heart breaks and hard accelerations were
below average and so that's the kind of
feedback that they would be getting now
of course we all know that we're all
above Davidge right so
you know it would be big news to any of
us to get an orange exclamation mark
that says that we do too much swerving
and anybody's ever argued with someone
maybe their spouse or someone else about
whether they're breaking too hard will
be familiar with the idea that everyone
thinks they're above average so this is
what this is what we what we got and
then just analyzing this experiment in
Chicago we have about 24,000 drivers in
the control group and 36,000 drivers in
the treatment group now this this
experiment was actually run more broadly
but we're analyzing it in Chicago
because that's where we've really delved
in but we have some power problems the
experiments a little bit underpowered
for our purposes but we we are we had
the data set from Chicago and so that's
what we analyzed so just to be clear why
the experiments a little bit
underpowered here so what we look at now
now this experiments a little bit tricky
because it's the you're gonna be assign
this at the driver level some drivers
will never look at the tab and so
they're gonna have a treatment effective
zero so we're gonna the first thing we
can do is analyze this as an intent to
treat analysis where you've been given
access to the information but you may
not comply with reading the information
and then we also do a sort of a
treatment on the treated analysis where
we try to instrument for whether you
actually looked at the app by with your
assignment
and that's basically just gonna inflate
the estimates because we can observe
whether you actually looked at the app
or not so what we see basically is that
the results are a little noisy but they
are you know generally we're seeing
especially in this the treatment that
the instrumental variables analysis
positive and statistically significant
impact on your safety scores from
interaction with the app um but then
when we break this out more finally we
look at whether you're in the bottom
10th percentile before the experiment
starts as a pretreatment variable and we
because this is basically just going to
be giving you exclamation marks the
theory would be that this should this
experiment should really really have an
effect on people who were driving badly
and so just taking a cut here we take
the people who were in the bottom 10th
percentile on these on these scores
before the experiment started and we
find that that's where all the treatment
effect
are coming from and those so the people
who got the orange exclamation points
basically the kind of people who are
likely to get orange exclamation points
were impacted by this so to summarize we
find that over X is significantly higher
quality than taxis in terms of safety
metrics while the incentives surely play
a role the whole body of evidence
suggests that the incentives are not the
only thing going on and actually these
informational nudges are playing an
important role we also see that the uber
X drivers are driving or more responsive
to passenger preferences than taxis so
we'd say the myth that modern
marketplaces provide lower quality at a
lower cost is rejected in the data
monitoring rating reviews and nudges can
compensate for the reduced screening and
hiring and I think but just again the
big takeaway I have actually beyond this
paper is that we should be seeing we
should expect to see over the next five
years less emphasis on this costly
activity of making a consumer you know
dinging a driver which feels bad to
everybody and more emphasis on telemetry
and direct measurement of behavior and
that that's more reliable has better
statistical properties and and then can
also you be be used to help get the
service providers to improve just by
their own intrinsic motivation rather
than other
[Applause]
Oh lots of questions along the way any
any more questions are okay so the stars
are public but the information about
this details is not right they oh yeah
which which is a difference in the
treatment this may be different in terms
of intrinsic person extrinsic motivation
said that better also
have you thought about you know would
you make it public or not would you
recommend that this more precise
information is meant for making public
or you think part of the treatment is
that it's really triggering intrinsic
motivation yes so the question is like
should we be making these these things
public and so there's probably the
driving thing and practice is gonna be
how it makes the workers feel because
that if there's a huge disutility you
know then you have to account for that
in the overall welfare of the platform
and so actually I had a PhD student John
Kolstad who's here at Berkeley more than
10 years ago wrote his PhD thesis about
providing information about quality
privately to doctors and the doctors in
the hospitals of course violently
opposed any kind of score carding and so
if you take that as a political reality
it turns out that you could get the
doctors to do better just by telling
them that their complication rates were
high so I think in a political setting
and a personal setting where people do
feel disutility about these things it's
interesting that you can get a lot of
the bang for the buck just out of
telling them whether you want to
incorporate it in a broader score I
think it's it could be hard for
consumers to understand and I think that
is the communication of these things in
a world where people aren't really
spending a lot of time to understand the
way the votes
as well so my guess is that the way this
balancing all considerations given that
you can get a lot of the way there
without making it public that's probably
going to be the way it plays out in
practice it's just that this proxy is
public like the Stars which is rude and
wrong and you know it's public and then
they want concrete which could be more
useful it's not yes so exactly so what
you would you could imagine doing and
this would require a lot of study by the
platforms would be a major change is to
stop showing the Stars and to show
something else which is just some sort
of rating some crude rating that you and
then they don't tell you exactly what it
is because they're going to be changing
it all the time and things like that so
I agree that this this I'm definitely
with you that like the star rating is
going to decline yeah yeah yeah we're
running over okay so we don't want to
cut into the break anymore so we have a
break until 11:00 and we'll resume -
you're from it is laggy and
okay
[Applause]